my mother acts in the number of films
particularly in Goodfellas in 1989 1990
and to her she perceived it as my son's
making a film and these are my son's
friends it wasn't De Niro wasn't Joe
pescio wasn't you know uh the level of
uh these incredible actors it was
literally my son's friends they knew
each other very well you know Katie had
cooked endlessly for them so they were
very comfortable all together and then
at one point the only Direction he gave
her was pick up the painting mother
right so she picked up the painting and
then she improvised the great lines oh
that's going Easton the other one is
going west so what he would never really
direct her he would just put her in the
scene because he knew she was the
perfect thing to make Bob and Joe uh
improvise together and she would get
yourself a nice girl I get a nice one
almost every
yeah but get yourself a girl so just so
you could settle down
and settle down almost everything I put
that in the morning I'm free I love you
I want to be with you